shaming female promiscuity has a
tragedy of the commons effect in The
Mating Market one woman offers jobs on
the second date harder for other women
to keep them in reserve until the fourth
date is their special treat this creates
a downward spiral of young women feeling
like they have to offer more sex two
more guys just to stay in The Mating
Game thus shaming is a way of
enforcing a more restrained sexual Norm
on other women so that not all women
have to become more promiscuous than any
one of them would like that blew
my mind unless you have this kind of
game theory perspective it's really hard
to understand why slot shaming is mostly
done by women to other women it also
makes a lot of sense around why women
tend to be the enforcers of shaming
because women are the ones who have an
incentive to protect the sexual
Marketplace from becoming a price war of
easy sex and this is also why the main
opponents of sex work are often married
women because they have the most to lose
if you just ask what's the incentive to
impose a certain social Norm on human
sexuality often it's not that hard to
figure out why it's happening